45000 euros d'amendé un an de prison
voilà ce que l'on pourrait risquer si
l'on diffuse l'image elle d'un visage de
tout élément permettant l'identification
d'un policier ou gendarme en
intervention portant atteinte à son
intégrité physique ou psychique
c'est ce que prévoit l'article 24 du
texte sur la loi de sécurité globale si
jamais le texte est adopté il faudra
désormais flouter le visage et du
policier en actions si vous voyez un
problème qui relève du code pénal vous
aurez le droit de le filmer et de le
transmettre au procureur de la
république
si vous voulez le diffuser sur internet
de façon sauvage vous devrez faire
flouter les visages des policiers des
gendarmes
une situation qui aura donc fortement
compromise une certaine affaire benalla
nous sommes le 1er mai 2018 ici place de
la contrescarpe à paris ta aboaf filmé
l'intervention d'un homme casqué et
portant un brassard de police en train
de violentes et des manifestants il ya
des crs qui se mettent à bloquer les
entrées et sorties de la place contre
oscar la tension augmente la tension
monte très rapidement benalla il arrive
au moment où le jeune homme est
neutralisée par terre et que vincent
crasse le tiens on le tient le tient par
le col et lui demande des explications
sur eux
en fait on n'a pas le contexte unis
monde sait qui c'est qui est le jeune
homme lui dit je vais t'expliquer dès ce
mois ci le supplie au fait de se calmer
et donc à ce moment là alexandre arrive
la crap par le coup l'étranglent et
commence à lui asséner des coups de
poing et c'est à ce moment là qu'on sait
qu'on crie d'arrêter arrêter les images
publiées dans la foulée sur twitter sont
choquantes et si la loi avait été en
vigueur à l'époque elle n'aurait pas
permis d'identifier alexandre benalla
qui ne fait pas partie des forces de
l'ordre mehta à boire ce qui le filme
pensent avoir affaire à un policier
je ne savais pas qu'il s'agissait de
benalla un collaborateur de macron mais
je voulais alerter sur les violences de
ce policier en civil si j'avais flouté
la sphère benalla n'existerait pas une
affaire qui on se souvient à secouer
l'elysée chi l'ancien collaborateur
d'emmanuel macro est visé par six
procédures judiciaires a bien distincts
concernant les violences policières du
1er mai 2010huit l'instruction s'est
achevée en octobre dernier et la justice
doit plancher sur la tenue ou non d'un
procès mais dans ce cas précis on voit
bien que la vidéo h
rôle clé direction cette fois le quai
branly nous sommes le 3 janvier 2020 un
livreur en scooter de 42 ans subit un
contrôle routier ou le il meurt 48
heures après son interpellation
très vite les avocats de la famille de
la victime s'appuie sur des vidéos de
témoins ayant filmé la scène pour
dénoncer une bavure
on a assassiné mon fils c'est ce que
aujourd'hui quand mon petit fils de 21
ans et de manques il y en a assassiné
ton père voilà y'a pas d'autre mot tant
que j'avais pas vu de photos tant que
j'avais rien lu j'ai dit on sait pas ce
qui s'est passé
la vérité aujourd'hui c'est quand on
voit les images et bons d'achats signer
mon fils voilà qu'on le veuille ou non
des images amateurs qui vont donc encore
une fois tout changé et qu'ils vont
surtout permettre l'identification des
policiers mis en cause
elles vont même relancé un débat
national sur le placage ventrale une
technique policière controversée
d'autres vidéos retrouvées dans le
portable de cédric joue via et celle
enregistrée par alain des policiers vont
être ajoutés au dossier
l'une d'entre elles interpellent les
enquêteurs celle de cédric souvient
durant son interpellation ici sur les
quai branly à paris où on entend dire à
plusieurs reprises
j'étouffe des mots que les policiers
assurent ne pas avoir entendu par la
suite
trois d'entre eux seront mises en examen
pour homicide involontaire les exemples
lors des manifestations des gilet jaune
ne manque pas également les policiers
frappant des manifestants dans un burger
king
jérôme rodriguez figure du mouvement
recevant un éclat de grenade par les
forces de l'ordre dans l'oeil ou encore
un crs jetant un pavé dans la foule des
vidéos qui ont toutes abouti à
l'ouverture d' enquête sur des bavures
policières les actions controversées de
la police sont systématiquement
désormais filmées et mises en ligne
l'importance de ces images on l'a vu est
primordial pour les enquête de l'igpn ou
la justice cette loi discuté ce mardi à
l'assemblée nationale va donc remettre
sur table un débat sur la liberté
d'expression est d'informer datant on
peut le dire de 1789